good morning believe nation today's
message is use your time wisely over to
you Nelson Mandela I hated oppression
and when I think about the past the type
of things they did I feel angry you have
a limited time to stay on earth you must
try and use that period for the purpose
of transforming your country into what
you desire it to be so I just got back
from Madrid you guys have seen some of
the videos on the channel and people
asked me how was the trip how did it go
did you have fun and honestly when I was
there in Madrid I had a couple extra
mornings and afternoons off and it
bothered me I was sitting there you know
beautiful Madrid lots of places to
travel to and see and soak in the
culture and all I wanted to do was speak
to the people that I was there to speak
to I wanted to connect with them I
wanted to help them I you know
increasingly hated to travel because of
how much time it takes away from what
I'm doing here and so my thinking was
okay I'm going to Madrid I'm going to
help this group of people it's taking
almost a full week of my schedule from
Sunday to Thursday plus jetlag to do one
speech and then one Q&A session and if I
didn't have a major impact on those
people's lives during those two sessions
then I wasted my time sure I got paid to
go but that's not the point I don't do
things for money in my business I do
things because I want to have an impact
and as I was walking around the streets
of Madrid you know in the mornings off
that I had it was great to take in the
views all I was thinking was I need to
make the most use of that time when I'm
talking to them and really touch them
because if I don't touch somebody's life
and make them want to have an impact and
make a change and I fail then this has
just been a huge waste of my time
and I shouldn't have come and that added
pressure on me to really deliver and
step up unfortunately they said it was
the most provocative session that they
saw at the event and so that's good and
that's the that's the mindset that I go
into I try to take into every day I'm
not always successful but I try to take
it into every day and that today is
important I have a limited time I don't
want to waste doing things that that are
not adding value that are not bettering
me as a human beings are not furthering
the purpose that I have and I just
implore you to do the same thing stop
wasting time make your life more
important have goals that matter look at
your day and and don't let days and
weeks go by that you aren't making
progress on making yourself a better
person and making an impact because I
don't want to be the guy who's 70 or 80
years old looking back on my life and
regretting that I didn't spend more time
doing whatever it was right and I want
you to do the same thing make today
matter make this week matter make your
life matter it's important so the
question today today is I want to know
what's keeping you back from making time
important what are the time wasters in
your life right now leave it in the
comments below and I'm going to join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events pressive
and espresso TV go